let's hear from a few more people via
the David Pacman show Discord which you
can find at davidpackman.com
Discord we are going to start right now
right away with no delay with Dylan from
Kentucky Dylan what is on your mind
today
hey David uh been a long time listeners
first time I've ever got to call and
speak to you so
I'll be a little shaky here you're doing
great so far my friend thank you friend
hey so I think for a long time it's sort
of been seen as the as the linchpin for
what might uh fix you know
um our democracy here is is the issue of
campaign Finance reform
um and I wonder I would like to get your
thoughts on how that
can and will relate to the upcoming
Supreme Court decision on Moore versus
Harper and thus giving um
state legislators more power
over our our elections in general and I
would like to just uh mute and listen to
you uh talk about that for a moment so
one of the things uh when people call in
and they say David uh sir you know
sometimes they have tears in their eyes
and they say what do you think are the
most important issues facing American
politics uh the list that I've typically
given over the last few years as I say
campaign Finance is one such issue
media coverage of politics is another
issue and it's very much influenced by
how we Finance elections third is how we
run our elections meaning first past the
post in most cases and also the
Electoral College uh for the presidency
I would like to see that changed and
fourth is climate change in the sense
that if your city is under water or the
pollution in your city is so bad that
it's going to be hard to be an activist
for the issues that we care about unless
we deal with climate change in a in a
sensible way and then sometimes we'll
also talk about access to health care
because if you're sick and don't have
access to health care it's also hard to
be an activist whether you care about
education or abortion or whatever Access
to Health Care would also be another
issue I still stand by that but I think
that we need to be much more sort of
strategic when we simply say campaign
Finance reform I almost think it's too
broad for some people to understand what
we mean and so a much more specific but
still understandable set of of ideas
should be there and I think within that
the most important ones would be
public financing of Elections rather
than you know just unlimited spending
whatever you can raise you can spend so
public financing of Elections would be
number one doing everything we can to
eliminate the ability of dark money to
come in right now even though they're
quite strict limits in terms of
contributions directly to candidates I
forget whether it's 2700 per cycle or or
exactly what the number is
um there is the ability to donate huge
amounts of money to packs and the money
can sort of be laundered and you don't
know who's spending what where the
money's coming from in all cases
necessarily so that's really where I
would would try to focus that
conversation and to be honest and I know
now I'm getting a little bit off the the
exact question
I would like to see us the left
become way more specific and strategic
with all of these issues so like for
example when we talk about climate
change okay climate change
we should be more specific in terms of
what we're talking about because
sometimes the things that are repeated
about climate change aren't really the
biggest concerns there's a really good
book called precipice by Toby ORD which
both argues I recently read the book
it's a couple years old it both argues
climate change is a massive issue that
we have to deal with and also some of
the statements made about it are a
little bit hyperbolic for example if
climate goes if it gets if the climate
gets warmer by two degrees on average
we're going to starve because we're not
going to be able to grow food when you
look into that actually it being a
little warmer would probably make it
easier to grow food in more parts of the
world the issues are different ones and
we should try to be more specific in all
of these uh all of these issues I hope
to some degree I'm answering the
question Dylan
um and uh I hope to hear uh from you
again very very soon